لحظة الأخبار العاجلة لإحداث
تطور كبير في الحرب في أوكرانيا بعد
أسابيع من الضغط من الحلفاء الغربيين
ألمانيا التي أعلنت هذا الصباح أنها
سترسل دبابتين ليوبارد إلى
منطقة الحرب لتنضم إلى الولايات المتحدة في القيام
بذلك ، إذا انضم فريد بلانكتون إلينا ويعيش في
الشرق  نظرة أوكرانيا ، هذه أخبار ضخمة
صحيحة ومرحب بها للغاية بالنسبة لفلاديمير
زيلينسكي وأوكرانيا كلها ،
نعم نعم بالتأكيد ، وقد
سمعت بالفعل بالأمس عندما كان نوعًا ما
يتسرب من خلال هذا الأمر على الأرجح
سيحدث أن الأوكرانيين
سعداء للغاية بالتأكيد.  حصلوا على
بعض التفاصيل من الألمان يقولون
إن هدفهم الرئيسي هو إنشاء
كتيبتين من الدبابات في النهاية من
المفترض أن يحصل عليها الأوكرانيون والتي
ستكون حوالي 88
دبابة قتالية رئيسية من طراز ليوبارد ، لكنهم يقولون أيضًا
أنه في الخطوة الأولى بشكل صحيح  الآن
سيرسلون 14 من هذه الدبابات بأسرع ما
يمكن ، ويقول الألمان أيضًا إنهم
يريدون تدريب الأوكرانيين على
البدء بأسرع ما يمكن ، وكان هناك
فارق بسيط مثير للاهتمام وهو أننا حصلنا على الخشخاش
من الألمان كما يقولون
أنهم سيعطون الإذن
للدول الأوروبية الأخرى التي تمتلك
هذه الدبابات لإرسال
دبابات القتال الرئيسية هذه أيضًا إلى الأوكرانيين ،
وهذا يعني أن الأوكرانيين يمكنهم
الحصول على الكثير من هذه الدبابات بسرعة كبيرة
لأن الكثير من الدول الأوروبية لديها
هذه الدبابات.  نحن نعلم الآن بالطبع أن
كل هذا جاء بعد بعض المفاوضات الصعبة جدًا
بين الألمان والولايات المتحدة
في النهاية ،
يبدو أن الولايات المتحدة تتراجع أيضًا عن
إرسال دبابات القتال الرئيسية التابعة لأبرام إلى
أوكرانيا ، وكذلك بالطبع الأوكرانيون
سعداء جدًا بالحصول على هذه الدبابات.  دبابات
ألمانية الصنع وأمريكية تصنع
المستقبل غير البعيد مثل الرجال
وفريد ​​، كان هناك رد فعل
هذا الصباح من روسيا ، حسنًا ،
أنت على حق تمامًا ، وكنت في
الواقع أتراسل مع
المتحدث باسم الكرملين ديميتري بيسكوف وأه قليلاً
بينما قبل كل شيء وقبل كل شيء كان يقول
أنه من الواضح أن الروس يقولون إن
هذا سيزيد من التوتر هنا في
القارة.  قال
السفير الروسي في الولايات المتحدة إنه
خرج وقال إن
دبابات أبرام التي تدخل أوكرانيا سيتم
تدميرها من قبل الروس بالطبع
قال الروس حتى الآن إنه
تقريبًا كل نظام سلاح جديد
للولايات المتحدة وحلفائها  لم يتم إرسال
أي من هذا حتى الآن ، ومرة ​​أخرى ، فإن
الأوكرانيين سعداء جدًا بهذه
القرارات ، وأعتقد حقًا أنهم
سيحصلون على دبابات أكثر بكثير مما
كانوا يعتقدون في الأصل ، قبل
ما يُتوقع أن يكون روسيًا حقيقيًا
تصعيد في الربيع لذا التوقيت الرئيسي
يشكرك فريد على الإبلاغ على
أرض الواقع في أوكرانيا